chris hogan here i've spent a lot of
time traveling speaking and talking with
people all around the country a topic
that continues to get me fired up is the
self-made millionaire and their success
story
I've even devoted segments of my
podcasts retire inspired to talking with
these self-made millionaires you're
about to step into the life of someone
who crossed over to millionaire status
on their own terms your strategy
dictates your tactics and what I always
used to say at work this is what I want
and therefore I'm going to tell my money
to do this
today you don't want to miss it people
this is millionaire
[Music]
so my name is Jim and this is my wife
Mary my lovely wife Mary and we live
just south of Bend Oregon so I'm a
semi-retired high tech executive I do
business consulting now we do things
with both a ministry and as a business
so we're currently leading Financial
Peace University class then we work on
with people one on one for with coaching
I'm going to do a variety of volunteer
work my therapy dogs going to a hospital
and helping patients with physical
therapies as well as emotional therapy I
wake you thank you I grew up in a family
on the youngest of six and I grew up in
a family that was always very secure we
might not have had a tremendous amount
of money but we always had food on the
table I can vividly remember many times
where my parents would say things like
we're going to pay off the house so I
was raised in that and so I don't know
that I necessarily ever wanted to be a
millionaire but what I wanted to do is
make sure that myself and then my family
my household was going to be secure long
term so I focused very hard on getting a
good degree I'm an electrical engineer
and say I studied hard but I did
graduate with a 301 I got it over that
bar that last minute racquetball planter
really saved my bacon for me it was just
what's work really hard and let's
understand how to be successful what I
was not good at was managing money and
one of the most fantastic things about
the lady that I met and that I wanted to
marry I realized that she was incredibly
good at managing the money and watching
it I don't think I ever even thought
about the millionaire status at all
until more recently and
when we realize that we were I guess
millionaires it was an interesting
feeling but it wasn't something that we
had necessarily set out to achieve my
father always used to tell me you have
to learn from sweeping the floors you
learn at everything it is that you do so
I was incredibly fortunate like I said I
got in a lexical engineering degree and
electrical engineers would be lots of
things and I had some experience with
analog video and I got hired by my
company to actually work on a team that
was taking video for the first time off
of the television and putting it onto
the computer it was the first digital
video ever created and I got to be a
team of about 40 or 50 people that made
that whole dream a reality for the world
so everybody you're welcome my ideas
were not what was important it was
letting everybody else at the technology
so we put digital video in the hands of
the world and then we saw the world turn
it into some wonderful stuff so
technology is emotionless it's a it's a
keep the emotion that people put around
it is very important and you know money
is the same way money is emotionless
money is a tool that you can use for
various things it's what you do with the
money and it's how you do things with it
so these days I do a little bit of
woodworking and I don't have all the
fancy tools that the tools that I have I
have learned to use very effectively I
don't want to be awful
I want to exceed and the best thing that
I can do is I can find the experts that
help me what I think is fantastic about
all our AMC solutions and all the things
that Chris Hogan for instance provides
on retirement if it gives you all sorts
of amazing tools all you have to do is
just maximize your effort on working
with those tools and you will find that
you use them most effectively for your
own budget and your own dreams
what's great about dreaming is it truly
is a dream you can start with a concept
you can embellish on it the point for us
isn't that you need to have one green
the point is that you can dream in a
variety of ways and sometimes when
you're talking about the cash flow plan
what we're really talking about is your
dreams you sure you might be talking
about okay well is the $50 going to go
here is the $50 going to go here but
after a period of time that conversation
goes to you but we really want to do
that we really want Kevin in the woods
or we really want a new car or we really
want to retire with dignity but the
great opportunity for us is by having a
green by starting with that and by
talking about it and thinking about it
and continuing to focus on it that dream
becomes sharp it doesn't matter if
you're sweeping the floor it doesn't
matter whether you're onboarding a new
intern it doesn't matter whether you're
managing a 300 million dollar budget if
you are wildly and fiercely enthusiastic
about something you will succeed at it a
dream that you get enthusiastic about
will never be blurry it will be high
definition
I never made as much money as anybody
around us we just understood that just
because we make this much money doesn't
mean you need to live off as much money
for us image I've never mattered and
people have a hard time envisioning how
they can get to be millionaires or
arrive because they want to keep up with
the Joneses we're more concerned about
loving our life and what we can do and
how we can help others rather than
impressing somebody else we would just
be very intentional and I think a lot of
it was not a matter of how much we made
but how much we saved and how we went
about doing things as Chris Hogan said
it doesn't matter how much or how little
you make you can still do a whole lot of
stupid I've known people who make much
lower incomes and I then people often
say how do you survive on that and they
don't have to provide big drives because
they have a plan what we did is we
decided we're going to live within our
means whatever those means are we're
going to give first we're going to save
second and we're going to continue to
focus on our dreams it wasn't that we
ever had a lot of money it wasn't that
we ever saved everything we lived a
lifestyle that we could talk about and
that fit our dreams and enabled us to
get to the point where we are today so I
really want to say to the people out
there that it is possible to live your
dreams and to be excited and
enthusiastically pursuit life and you
will achieve what you want if you want
it bad enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]